i saw jlo and era in a-rod not that long
ago
and i thought that it was an
intervention i thought that they had
planned this
because it was my mom and dad and jayla
and a-rod
and they were just like yeah you just
can't be
caught up in what's going on that's
wrong you said everything that i needed
to hear
that is insane
charlie hi i'm so happy to see you um
what a what a year for you um
and now to be a published author i feel
like
um you have had so many irons in the
fire
are you exhausted it's obviously
a lot with everything that i'm working
on but it's not exhausted
as much as i'm just proud
like proud of everything that i've been
able to do in such a short period of
time and
and i normally don't talk about myself
like that but looking back
and and seeing people make videos of all
of the things that i've been able to do
in such a short period of time it's just
like
wow like that's really crazy something
that i obviously never expected
just because it happened like that
but i'm really proud of myself and
especially the book
that's crazy never ever thought that i
would do that but i mean
it's here and i'm happy i love this i
got a chance to read it
um and i i love that you're not shying
away
um this is not something that's very
like top level i mean you really get
into
relationships being in the public eye
like a lot of your
i think people get to know you in a way
that they maybe don't know you if they
follow you was that your intention
definitely especially going into the
relationships part
sometimes people forget that i was a
high schooler
and i went to middle school with
everyone else and i
was a very normal teenager and i still
am and i feel like that's the part where
sometimes there's a bit of a
disconnection from social media to who i
actually
am and that was one of my main goals to
be like hey
we're exactly the same in so many ways
and
i feel like it's important for people to
know that because what i'm doing is not
something so out of this world when it
comes to day-to-day stuff
yeah and i think that's one of the
things that you have in common with like
the biggest celebrities in the world
that i've
i've interviewed as well like i mean you
can interview scarlett johansson
or oprah winfrey they still have their
insecurities they still have those
things where they're unsure of what
they're putting out into the world and i
think that's a really normal thing
and i think you make a lot of people
feel less alone when you
oh my god charlie is like hey i don't
know what i'm doing sometimes
like i'm confused sometimes i'm feeling
insecure sometimes i'm really proud of
you i think that's a big deal
thank you yeah i feel like that's
something that i've been
i i know it's important because same as
everyone else i grew up watching people
online and seeing
how perfect they are and no one really
gets into the
hey i'm not perfect i have lots of
things that i want to work on to make
myself feel better and
there's things that i still have to do i
still have to at the end of the day go
to school i still have to
eat three meals a day i have to clean my
room i have to do chores around the
house like it's
the same thing and i feel like having
people know that
i do those exact same things that they
do is something that's a little bit
comforting and it brings us together and
it's like
i don't want to put myself on this
pedestal that i am perfect 24 7 because
i'm very much not i have my bad days i
have my down days i
live a normal life at the end of the day
but i post on social media and i feel
like
so many people try to play themselves as
perfect and i just
cannot be that person i can't do that to
myself that's
too difficult too difficult and also
you're doing it for 100
million fans stop playing with a red
light green light gun
can you even wrap your head around like
what a hundred million people standing
anywhere would be like this is a large
group of people charlie
that's one of the things that i miss so
much is like i think back to when i went
to milan and when i got to
meet people and even though we didn't
speak the same language it was just a
connection and it was a real human
connection and that's what i missed so
much is like hearing these stories about
how
i might have gotten someone to go back
into dance lessons or
had someone start feeling confident in
themselves and like that's what i miss
so much and it makes me feel so good
that
i can help even if it's just one person
like that's all that
i really want to do with what i have and
and i feel like this book might help a
lot
to really let people know like hey you
might not be feeling great right now but
you're not alone and there's
a million other people that feel the
exact same way that you do and that's
totally fine
and then on top of it to celebrate 100
million
fans you donated a hundred thousand
dollars to dance charities and studios
why was that so important to you
for me i grew up with a lot of
anxiety and i kept every single thing
that i was feeling inside
of me and i feel like people really
don't understand the importance of
movement and how dance can really change
someone's life because
if i was never put into dance i would
not have any confidence
i would not like myself and be able to
go out and have people take pictures of
me and
and post videos for millions of people
to see it i would have never been able
to do that
and even from a smaller scale when i was
in middle school
if i did not have the studio owners that
i had that
let me stay till midnight at the studio
just
dancing my heart out because that's all
that i could do at the time
before i could ever actually talk about
how i was feeling
i would be stuck in my room in this
little bubble just
not even knowing who i am and
a lot of the studios that i'm donating
to help
people with disabilities with seizure
disorders or epilepsy and things like
this and i feel like it's so important
to really
let everyone know how dance is for
everybody and it can help
everybody it doesn't matter if you're
the most flexible or most technically
trained even if you're just dancing your
room by yourself
that can help and i feel like it's so
important to let everyone know that
no matter what's going on in your life
it's it feels good to just
let go and and move to music or
to whatever it is and just be yourself i
could have danced with you all day
that's for another interview
um okay so essentially charlie who
essentially is charlie charlie is
a lot of things at the end of the day i
am
a girl that likes to dance and likes to
spend time with her friends and
likes to be around her family and is
very normal
and very down to earth and very chill
and
likes to just watch movies and have fun
but
when you look deeper into it you see
that
i am not exactly the person that
i portray myself on my tic toc videos
i usually look very put together i
usually
make sure all my moves are perfect but
that's not how it is
and i have friend problems
i have difficulty in school with
being behind or maybe not learning as
fast as everyone else and
and there's still things like that and i
feel like that's
kind of what i wanted to show in this
book is like
everyone puts me on this place to where
she's perfect all the time so she has to
be
all the time but it's like this is the
time when you're 16 this is where you
make all your mistakes and where you
grow and learn and become a better
person
so it's like i really want to show
everyone in a book
really telling everyone what i want them
to know
in the best way possible where i don't
have comments
that people can say that's not right or
she should do this better why'd you do
this so why'd you put this in it it's a
book
you read it and that's it
there's no place for negative feedback
this is a place for me to share who i am
without having to hear anything back i
love this so there's this chapter called
in the public eye and you're talking
about
no big deal i mean jlo jimmy fallon
kelly ripa
what's the best advice or the coolest
meeting story of meeting like a
celebrity out there
oh my goodness i saw jlo and a-rod not
that long ago and
i thought that it was an intervention i
thought that they had planned this
because it was my mom and dad and jayla
and a-rod
and they were just like yeah you just
can't be
caught up in what's going on that's
wrong it's just like you really need to
push forward and i was like
who set this up because i was in such a
bad place for
such a long time letting everything that
anyone said just bring me down
and then after it was over i was like
okay like seriously who planned this
like this could not have been
uh whatever and they were like no we
just wanted you to come in and see our
new offices and i was like
this works out like this that you said
everything that i needed to hear
that is insane and just made me so happy
that
everything happens for a reason this
happened to make me get out of that
and be happy again and smile again and
mean it and
i feel like that's where i am now where
it's obviously ups and downs i mean i'm
emotional i'm a teenager it's gonna
happen
but those ups are just staying for
longer and that's what's so nice because
each of these people that i talk to
it's like helping remind me who i am and
why i'm here and why i do this every day
and it's just so important
there's a part of the book you're
talking about like you love your life
there's times you wish you could
press pause and you're talking about you
know
relationships and how people view you um
and one of the things about being a very
famous person is that everyone is going
to pick apart everything you do
especially your love life and you are a
teenager you are figuring this out
like you should how much pressure does
it put on you when everyone's so
involved in your relationships honestly
having people involved in your
relationships can
break it it can really
tear who you are down as a person and
when you start noticing yourself getting
into that
sort of place where you're like wow
these people are
more invested in seeing us fail
then they want to see us actually be
happy together it can be really
detrimental
and you just have to stay true to
yourself it happens with friendships
relationships
everything